on soir que se passe-t-il dans la
capitale ukrainienne
écoutez on attend comme maintenant
maintenant le 12e à 12e nuits le
couvre-feu qui va intervenir dans
quelques instants couvre feu très
strictes la loi martiale est très très
très très appliqué ici entre 20h et 7h
et on entend toujours là il n'y a pas de
trêve et bien des bombardements des
bombardements qui viennent bien du nord
ouest de la capitale à une vingtaine de
kilomètres cette ville satellitaire de
ir pinet boudhha nous étions avec
georges asbeck une partie de la journée
sur ce nouveau front en fête ou
où se concentrent les forces russes nous
étions à 1
km2 selon les forces du craignait n'est
bien kilomètres des forces russes il y à
un pilonnage incessant c'est un
spectacle assez incroyable de tirs de
mortiers de tirs d'artillerie de
bombardements incessants sur ceux sur
cette commune dira pin et surtout ses
scènes assez tragique 1 je le dois le
dire de centaines d'habitants avec leurs
enfants les grands parents leurs animaux
domestiques beaucoup d'animaux
domestiques dans ces quartiers
résidentiels et bien qu'ils traversaient
en fuyant ces zones de combat où les
combats s'intensifient on a passé un peu
de temps une partie de la journée dans
cette sur ce nouveau front il y à une
ratification de ces combats encore une
fois ce rouleau compresseur militaires
russes semblent s'appliquer pour arriver
à avoir après avoir bloqué l'est le nord
et bien à cette partie ouest maintenant
qui se concrétise
on peut entendre je ne sais pas si vous
entendez encore une fois des explosions
des bombardements qui viennent dire
pin's éteint ma vraiment là que là c'est
là que l'armée russe pilonnent et donc
pour fermer et continuer bien
l'encerclement de kiev pour laisser
aujourd'hui que la partie sud libre mais
aujourd'hui tout le monde retient son
souffle à ce soir c'est vrai qu'il ya
énormément de rumeurs et bien sûr une
offensive n'ont pas finalement une
tentative d'encerclement complet de kiev
est d'ailleurs au moment où je vous
parle il ya des convois militaires qui
c'est la première premier soir que nous
voyons est bien des convois de
militaires qui qui convergent au milieu
en plein centre-ville en fait là on se
trouve c'est bien que ont ce départ on
se prépare à une défense de la capitale
avec cet encerclement ce siège qui
pourraient commencer à ses bientôt en
tout cas on sait ici que c'est qu'une
question de jours
merci cyril